the overarching goal behind everything
just to to keep in the back of my head
for all this stuff is we want to make
what we want to watch
and that actually it translates pretty
well towards like the entire business
and if you keep that in the back of your
head towards any part of what we do it
makes a lot of sense so when we consider
like what videos we're going to make
it's what what would we want to watch
what we what would we it's like a tongue
twister what would we want to subscribe
to that's the type of Channel we're
trying to build and then as far as
Revenue like we are in a position where
the AdSense on the videos makes a good
amount and so we do very very carefully
hand select like we're extremely picky
about when we work with sponsors because
they all we also want them to make a lot
of sense you're right we could decide to
make a sponsor the amount of no's I say
in my inbox like we could make a
sponsored video every single video for
the rest of time and and that would be a
very different Channel you wouldn't want
to subscribe to that channel but we
could do it if we wanted to make a lot
of money
um but yeah there are some sponsors
where it's it's a win-win for everyone
we see that it's a cool product and we
want to share it anyway and now it's
worth working with them and the whole
thing works out great so yeah we we do
have goals as far as expansion and and
building not just a team but uh I sort
of have like this dream video studio in
mind on the horizon and that's not going
to be cheap so we got to get there
somehow
but yeah there is a there is very much a
hand-picked very picky element about
when we do sponsored stuff and when we
plug stuff just because it's what we'd
want to watch so it sounds like it's
very much sort of craft first and
business second I guess
um and you can correct me if I'm wrong
but it sounds like kind of the business
exists for the purpose of the craft
rather than the other way around and I
guess this is something that Casey said
um we're at the North summit in Dubai he
was like a lot of creators make videos
to make money but he makes money so that
he can make more videos and so the the
making of the videos is just the
instrumental intrinsic joy that he gets
from his life would you say the same for
you like how do you balance kind of
craft versus business again assuming
that there's a there's a spectrum
between the two yeah that's a hundred
percent I had never heard that quote but
that's exactly how the way we see it
like if we are sitting here trying to
think how do we make more money what's
the point of making more money if we're
not going to do anything with it the
thing that we do with the money that we
make is turn around and make better
videos so yeah if at any point we are
like I said we we have Ambitions and in
order to reach those goals we do need to
make more money in order to be able to
afford to to attack those goals but it
is very much that making money is in
order to make videos for sure hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye